i've been asking this question of
everyone before we get into the movie um
what tv series would each of you like to
guest star on
the sopranos but it's done i loved mad
men so much but it's done
too i also like high maintenance i'd
like to be on that show
that show makes me laugh bobby for you
i'm going to start with um
is at this point getting a roll with ben
and melissa because you've been friends
with them for so long
is it literally a text message like hey
do you want to work
you know how does it work now yeah like
that
it really does i get a text hey dude
what are you doing in may
and then i usually i i mean i then i ask
are we going on vacation are we going on
a job
and then and then we clarify and then we
get on the horn and it is like that
it's a really nice thing it's not it's
not common you know uh
but when that happens you know you
recognize your good fortune and
uh and you clear the decks to be able to
do that so it's an easy call
uh palm uh uh ben and melissa tend to
work with a lot of the same people again
and again when you got when you made it
for this movie we're like
future movies yeah no i was so happy to
be a part of this movie and i would love
to work with them again
for sure yeah is this one of these
projects though
that because i've heard they're just a
blast to work with on set and very
easygoing
is this one of these things where you
almost like paid to be in it just
because it's like a vacation shoot or
was it actually
super challenging due to the effects and
the action
no no i i would get it that some people
would pay for this
it's really fun you know it doesn't feel
like a job it's like i mean
yeah so much fun it never feels like a
job
it really is it's fun all day long i
mean these guys have just figured it out
you know they got the same crew
the crew is fun they work quickly
they're well prepared
they don't work ridiculously long hours
they want to have a life they've got a
family
and you're just laughing all day so it
really is uh
it is that kind of uh it is that kind of
a set
they give out like funny little prizes
every day like every day there's a new
crew member who's like the crew member
of the day and
you know there's like it's it's just
great man everything about it is just
just reminds you over and over that how
lucky we are to be doing this and
they're
they're like the personification of that
kind of humility
uh i'm a big fan of jason bateman and
the thing about jason and i've seen him
work
uh on a set he makes he can really get
you to laugh
he's very good at improvising and i'm
just curious
uh what it was like working with him and
when you were a little mad you didn't
get to wear the the crab hands
he's so funny so like straight and like
funny and with this crap claws i mean
i don't know he's he's just amazing
and like knowing that and then watching
ozark you know the
you know the difference between i mean
it's amazing you know the range
yeah he's got incredible range the guys
that inc the guy is a master of the
deadpan
throw some crack crab claws on him and
he goes even like he goes even
more away from the joke so uh it's
like the best of both worlds because you
have like the physical humor of him in
crab claws
um i remember when i remember when we
were shooting the big fight scene at the
end and
she sees him that she sees that he's
betrayed her you know and
and we were
shooting he waited until we were
shooting it and she's like i don't
remember his name but she says something
to him and he
and he made that choice to like run
sideways
uh you know and that just killed me it
just killed me i just didn't see it
coming i mean
he didn't turn and run he just he just
crabbed walked his way
sideways out and i just died he just
died yep
um i already got to go i'm just going to
say um congrats on the movie
and uh you guys have a fantastic day
with your speed david
thanks steve